think of anything similar to happen with
crowd for me it will be huge and
everyone will use it and try and then
there's a dark side and the back fires
and people get tired of it people misled
or whatever it is and they just pull the
fun I think I'm not sure what's going to
happen and I'm really looking forward to
to see it because you know it alls be
the world it also affects me but I think
because the way it's growing it's not
gonna get to be like the next big thing
and be so popular and that will allow it
to grow in a more organic and natural
way and hopefully governments will you
know may close to you know promote it in
a way like the state system and and it
will grow healthy and you give it if
that happens you know I think is going
to become a funding model hopefully it
might happen that you know it goes
really big and because of that we make a
lot of things wrong which is you know
kind of happy right i don't think the
way kickstarter deals with perks is
right but you know at some point people
just gonna I think they're gonna figure
that out I'm thinking different ways of
doing it and scrappy got more natural
thing
I crushed my fingers for that
you